The 20th most common misconception about
Islam asked by the non-Muslim is that if
Islam is such a good religion that you
talk about good things are there then
why do you find Muslims who are
dishonest Muslims who cheat Muslims who
bribe why if Islam is a good religion
which has such good teaching teachings
then why do you find Muslims who cheat
who Bob Ub
the reply to this last misconception is
that one of the major reasons is the
media. The media promotes misconception
about Islam. The international media
there is virulent propaganda regarding
Islam and they bombard misconceptions
regarding Islam.
And I gave you the example earlier.
Something happens. For example, the
Oklahoma bombing in US headlines, MIDDLE
EAST CONSPIRACY, Middle East conspiracy,
Middle East conspiracy.
After many days
after investigation, they come to know
it was an American soldier, a US
national who did it. So it comes in new
only once. US national did it then
disappears from the media before the
person is caught. Middle East
conspiracy. MALA AND ISLAM VERY EASY.
Middle East conspiracy. When they come
to know the fact, it comes once and
vanishes. If a Muslim
whose name is Muslim does a terrorist
attack, if his name is Sultan or
Muhammad, oh, Muslim did terrorist
attack. IF A NON-MUSLIM DOES, there was
a mentally unstable person who killed
innocent people in New Zealand. Mentally
unstable.
The Muslim does it very stable man. If a
Muslim man marries a woman who's 18
years old WITH PERMISSION,
OH 50YEAR-OLD MAN MARRYING 18Y OLD
WOMAN, HEADLINES
WHEN A 50YEAR-OLD NON-MUSLIM RAPES A
6YEAR-OLD GIRL, IT COMES in news briefs.
Raping common in America every day 2,813
cases of rape. Do you find in the media?
NO, IT IS SO COMMON. NO PROBLEM. EVERY
DAY EVERY 37 SECONDS, one rape is taking
place. It's not reported.
But a Muslim man marries with
permission.
A girl of 18 year old. Oh, 50-year-old
girl, 50-YEAR-OLD MAN MARRYING 18Y old
girl headlines news raping is no news.
Comment
[laughter] every minute one or two rape
is taking place. No problem. Not worth
reporting. So the sins done by
non-Muslims ARE SO COMMON. IT'S NOT
WORTH REPORTING. MUSLIM DOES
HIGHLIGHTED. I agree that there are
black sheeps in a community. I'm not
saying all the people who claim to be
Muslims are good. I'm not saying that. I
know that there are black sheeps in a
community. There are Muslims who cheat.
There are Muslims who bribe. There are
Muslims who kill innocent people. But
they are in a minority. What does the
media do? What does the media does? It
picks up the black sheep of the Muslim
community and they portray as though the
exemplary Muslims.
Exemplary Muslim. This. and they give in
the newspaper headline because the media
is controlled by the non-Muslim.
If we analyze,
I know some Muslims WHO CAN DRINK
ALCOHOL, THE non-Muslim competition,
they can drink him under the table. I
know that. But the percentage very
small. We Muslims today in the world are
THE BIGGEST COMMUNITY OF TEA TOTERS
THAT DON'T TOUCH ALCOHOL AS A WHOLE. One
or 2%, 3%, 4% possible.
We are the biggest community that GIVES
THE MAXIMUM CHARITY AS a whole. NO ONE
CAN SHOW A CANDLE WHERE MODESTY is
concerned, where sobriety is concerned.
You may find some Muslim women going in
beauty context. Very few
as a whole. There is no Muslim who can
show us a candle where modesty is
concerned, where sobriety is concerned,
where charity is concerned, where
honesty is concerned.
And to understand a religion, don't look
at the followers. Study and analyze the
scriptures, the sources of the religion,
the Quran, and the authentic hadith.